she's Brienne of Tarth please welcome
Dylan Christie everybody he's dead let's
see where I am
Margaery Tyrell never
she said to start
get up herself Peterman everybody he
answers to feet on or reach
give it up ground me Alan he's one of
the directors of Game of Thrones he
directed episodes nine and ten this year
please welcome David Nutter everybody
she went jelly Hannah Murray
he said well darling please welcome
Justin Bradley everybody start Maisie
Williams please come with that and she's
the executive producer please welcome
Carolyn Strauss everybody and Liam you
can come out now as well Thank You Liam
magis very exciting because it's always
fun to see all of you guys together
because of the show of course we don't
see you together enough I'm amazing
Sophie last year here at Comic Con Thien
I'd say to say you guys see each other
in San Diego more than use to each other
in Westeros is that okay yeah and is it
nice this time of year when you can get
together and actually see the cast is
that nice for everybody yes it is
does anybody want to say otherwise or
when they're separately so here's what
I'm going to have how many of you
because we're at a very interesting
point of Game of Thrones where we are
now up to the books so how many of you
have read the books how many of you were
so curious as to the outcomes your
character need read ahead in any one
when you did the reading I did the home
did anyone did fans of the books ever
ruin it for you did people ever did you
have to like her event that's been
happening when people came up to you is
that something that would you were at
risk of people would come up and be like
our egos blinds and even though I didn't
know it but yeah yeah I'm this era where
I'm pretending I'm you and I did it and
now that we're I guess in the question
we're ready now that we're now beyond
the books how what level of secrecy are
they holding you guys - is it more
intense than ever
yeah like when you get scripts you have
to sign like a million things we can you
can't even tell me candy would say
there's a lot of secrecy Wow if there's
one
so obviously that's headed for Carolyn
for you guys that has to be a huge issue
this year and fans of the show I think
we'll obviously we've seen we'll follow
every piece of casting every location
photo do you have to try harder than
ever now that you are sort of at the
focal point of the show yeah world and
balance point and so I think you know
we've always tried to maintain a level
of surprise for people who watch the
show thank you thank you I with every
you know season it gets more and more
what are the conversation levels like
with George at this point and writers
for the show like how much you talking
to him - I think they talk to everything
you know as much as they have before I
mean he's laid out a lot of sort of what
his thinking was going forward and then
Danny negative jumped off from there got
it
I will say it's so wonderful to see all
of you out of costume because some of
them to wear some pretty lousy costumes
you guys should just wear sacks great
Alfie by Van Winkle see you're the best
and seeing you with ten fingers and ten
toes is just outstanding thank you thank
you you know II went through probably
one of the roughest seasons the last
couple of seasons yeah I think seasons
three four and five
yeah
I need one of my favorite things about
Nellie was you know fian finally making
a choice like make incision with that
side for you to read that to see that
you actually got to move in a different
direction if you've been oh yeah baby
was an actor it would have been
interesting see software could have gone
in perhaps it would have gone dark over
yeah it's nice to sort of see some light
at the end of the character I'm so happy
Gillian salmon finally got together this
year that was the show it doesn't like
for ten good things are you what are you
looking forward to with with your
relationship moving forward where do you
hope that it goes I think someone just
have more of the same
well I've often said I've said it before
that I think up until you know give me
you know giving yeah I always thought
the sound used to think about sex the
way that most people think about space
and so much it's something that goes on
these were looking to do with it I think
easy used to see from a purely kind of
academic standing by in a kind of
childlike we have another need right
here it's similar to the way I come with
dancing or something like that but the
thing about gimme turned up engaging a
bit of practical you know I just can't
I don't know enough about the science to
be able to finish that metaphor on so
you know thanks again school you want
around sex did you hear kill the one
Walker swung drum for a few seasons
telling everybody about it nobody
believed him tell what such as Sammy's I
reckon even less people who believe the
dragon of the fighting
it's one of the most incredible scenes
in the history of show well all I know
is for that sequence was two days of
second unit and we had ten days of
person that we shot it was about a ten
day experience for myself at ten
I just wanted to physically survive
unfortunately I did and the dragon
trainer just must be essential you gotta
have a great dragon trainer and good
treats yeah
Natalie Margaery one of the toughest
characters to figure out I feel like
she's an effect she's in a sympathetic
place now what I love about her then the
more she dislikes somebody the nicer she
is
a lot of fun yeah yeah I call Marjorie
she just they left her in a Cell yeah
yeah slowly she needs a shower and a
coffee Wendelin I don't want to blame
you for the things your character did go
ahead you had one job which was just a
Kevin I am too soon what can I say I
feel like I have to stand for three
months watching a window to wait for a
candle
give me a break
a little bit too much I'm ambitious
you see brands peer-review because I
think she's gonna enjoy you this season
you guys are a great team when you're
playing it's very hard to even know even
the books it's very some very good
person or is very very bad person who's
bears looking after himself
what are you not knowing fully because
we don't really know like what are you
rooting for embarrassed as you play him
like what hope is his core good
ultimately but but it's one of the
reasons I didn't read the books is
because you can only play in a moment
you can't play knowledge you can't play
I know what's going to happen next or
you know so you just play the moment and
then then that takes the responsibility
of you you just plain to see I think we
could all use a Paris he's he's made me
a lot of money
Liam I you know Masai I've been look we
don't really know and this wasn't on
camera as you guys do really nice job
you kill a lot of people really I don't
think that's kind of yeah
especially when he finds out what that
did
I try it I did trying that these people
will make me over here did I try true
story and now I'm told is important
Reese and I have known each other for
almost 20 years
oh here we go increase and increase was
auditioning for this she called me
because she knew that I would be the
kind of person who would have read these
books and asked me if I thought it was a
good part that I told you it was right
thank you sir you're welcome just refer
to one of the toughest scenes I think
for everybody to watch this year was the
burning scene with Shireen without a
very soon for everyone here there has to
be a great level of Lebanese leaving you
all backstage obviously you are not as
dark as the character she played was
that a hard scene to shoot no not at all
tough way there tough stuff setting and
everyone really needed to feel what's
going to happen to this young girl and
we were all into it they have actors
were all into the sequence the extras
were into it and it was just an
amazingly powerful moment that it was
just turned out just right it was a very
powerful scene this year there seems to
be you don't have a couple of times
where the audience thought things were
rougher than they were even used to at
the place when you spend a lot of time
Westeros it seems weird that you would
be ever caught off guard were you
surprised by that you know I think
people like to get involved in a
conversation and I think also a little
more you know your care
ders the more painful it is when
something that happens to them and
something like Tareen you know when that
happens stream I mean she's such a
really interesting and just feel for
this girl and but just because it's
painful doesn't mean it's not a good
point story and I think that's it wasn't
done because of the pain but it was done
inspired now every time most times
obviously a character dies in a show
you've always been able to grant blame
it on beyond her charge our apartment
you say the actors look this is in the
book we do now that you're a little bit
ahead you feel like people are lobbying
okay you're still gonna blame well
there's Sophia Maisie I would just say
like we're it's very hard for a start in
Westeros as we know but we sort of
started the show with the starts and I
just need to ask you guys to do whatever
you can you're lobbying Georgia are for
the creators and shows I really think we
need to stay alive they keep on doing
bad stuff to us yeah I'm tried all right
you